there seem to be two types of people
involved in the in the development of CG
you had engineers who deep down always
wanted to be artists and we're trying to
like sort of you know they had their
Preston Blair books and stuff in the
trend forgot that it is and then you had
artists who are trying to tell trying to
create images in more than a traditional
way and you you gave me a great quote at
one point you said a fine artist
mentality suited that of the research
scientist a creative person produced
ideas that would fit the constraints of
technology in order to emulate human
motion yeah and actually as an artist I
found this kind of research environment
to be appropriate because research is
where you've got to invent crazy things
see if they work really come up with new
ways of thinking and I particularly
focused on human motion I I because at
that time a lot of the computer graphics
were very these mathematical shapes kind
of mundane objects and I was intent I
wanted to get the human into the
computer and I thought a way of doing
that was to get a human figure to move
to get facial animation so in fact I ed
catmull had built maybe the first
computer you know probably the second
command computer model and at New York
Tech we were trying to get the model to
move to articulate the limbs so I took
on that project and that's where some of
the work I did with choreographer like
Twyla Tharp who as a choreographer was
trying to get humans to move
expressively we work together and I
created a computer-generated character
actually it was for a piece called the
Catherine Wheel which was aired on TV
PBS and BBC in 1982 and it was the first
time the public had seen a
computer-generated human character on
television so the the work of trying to
express use this tool to express the way
humans express to
to move in a realistic way and also
later I worked with Fred park and Lance
Williams and other people to get facial
animation going and utilize that in
music videos like the craft work video
that you mentioned
you